[Musique]
nous sommes le 10 octobre 2016
rencontres avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département avec ce
7 8 les invités aujourd'hui lundi vous
entendrez pascal rodier du secours
populaire français les yvelines il nous
parlera de ce ciné débat autour du film
1936 2016 les vacances c'est pas du luxe
c'est un droit elle ce sera demain au
ciné c'était lent pour un événement
préparé dans le cadre des 80 ans des
congés payés justement et puis annie
couton la présidente des cougars de
montigny le bretonneux l'équipe de
baseball retrouve la première division
les objectifs et les ambitions du club
à suivre elle les congés payés l'une des
conquêtes sociales majeures date de 1936
et du front populaire et tous la fête
ses 80 ans un anniversaire presque
passée inaperçue alors que se tenait les
discussions autour de la réforme de la
loi travail mais derrière l'anniversaire
de cette conquête sociale il ne faut pas
oublier que nous ne sommes pas tous
égaux un enfant sur trois par exemple ne
part jamais en vacances bonsoir pascal
rodier vous êtes donc le président du
secours populaire français dans le
département des yvelines et pour ses 80
ans des congés payés vous allez
organiser demain soir au ciné c'est à
elle encourt un ciné débat autour de ce
film en 1936 2016 les vacances c'est pas
du luxe
c'est un droit qu'est ce qui a motivé
justement cette action c'était de
rappeler que même s'il ya toujours cette
discussion autour de la loi travail est
aussi une réalité derrière même si les
congés sont toujours là on peut pas
toujours bénéfique
wailly escient en plus la situation a
plutôt tendance à s'aggraver c'est à
dire que en fait il ya une précarité qui
va grandissante et
on se rend compte que malgré le fait
qu'on ait quasiment bouger d'un siècle
en fait en terme de bilan c'est à peu
près toujours aussi catastrophique c'est
à dire qu'on est à peu près au chiffre
de la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
en termes de design dans cette situation
une paupérisation il ya une
paupérisation et puis de l'autre côté
aussi
1 un coup à plus élevé des vacances pour
les personnes qui ont encore les moyens
de partir on parle des enfants tout
d'abord un enfant sur trois seulement
qui part et comment vous intervenez vous
aider on va réussir précisé que l'entrée
pour ce ciné débat par exemple coûtera 3
euros 50 mecs cet argent va servir et
permettra d un homme parti rosy on a
même droit de donner un peu plus
connexion serait bien voilà et en fait
si vous voulez nous pour les enfants on
a depuis très très longtemps un
dispositif qui s'appelle le copain des
vacances ou en fête des familles
bénévoles accepte de prendre un enfant
en vacances il ya de ça quelques années
par exemple il ya plutôt 3 3 à 4
semaines et maintenant c'est plutôt 15
jours parce qu'il ya aussi une
sociologie des vacances qui a évolué de
ce point de vue là et puis grâce à des
soutiens de partenaires d'entreprises
ont réussi aussi à proposer des colonies
de vacances ou des séjours sportifs pour
les enfants
une solidarité qui fonctionne bien
encore aujourd'hui oui ça fonctionne
alors bon il ya je vous cache pas que
c'est un petit peu plus difficile de
trouver des familles d'accueil bénévoles
parce que bas comme je disais il ya
c'est un petit peu évolué pour les
durées de séjour pour les gens donc il
ya aussi pour eux le besoin de se
retrouver dans leur propre famille pour
ceux qui partent en vacances je pense
que ça joue un peu et puis il ya eu
quelques petites réticences liées à des
affaires passe et combat français mans
favoriser aussi pour certains parents le
le réflexe ou l'envié où le souhait de
confier son enfant c'est un acte quand
même important confier son enfant à des
inconnus sont pas forcément anodin
commun comme si vous encadrez bien
évidemment évidemment je vais surveiller
voilà c'est surveillé
il ya des extraits de casier judiciaire
qui se regarde et on vérifie
voilà ça ne part pas avec avec n'importe
qui
combien d'enfants partent quel bilan
peut faire un peu de vie différent des
actions pour le département alors sur le
département des yvelines il ya plus de
100 enfants qui partent que ce soit en
colonie de vacances ou en copains des
vacances sur l'année prochaine on espère
redynamiser le les familles d'accueil
bénévoles pour pouvoir accroître ce ce
bilan donc ça reste encore important
mais par rapport à d'autres années enfin
par rapport à il ya 20 ans le les
chiffres et ces moments importants on
parlait des enfants et de l'aide que
vous leur apportez ce que vous aider les
familles les adultes à partir aussi on
aide les familles complètes
alors là c'est encore plus onéreux que
c'est à partir des enfants donc
malheureusement là devant l'immensité
des besoins ce conte ce que l'on peut
apporter en terme de bilan mais
peut-être modeste mais on peut osciller
entre 20 et 40 familles selon les selon
les années et les possibilités de
partenariat qu'on obtient et puis on
essaye aussi maintenant d'organiser des
séjours seniors plus adapté pour les
comme le monde indique pour les
personnes plus âgées
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est cette
loi travail ces discussions qui ont eu
lieu alors qu'on célébrait les 80 ans de
la de ses congés payés est ce que la
remise en cause de certains de ses
acquis par exemple c'est aussi quelque
chose qui peut vous inquiétez pas ça va
pas dans le sens de plus de solidarité
a priori c'est quand même plutôt mal
parti donc c'est vrai qu'on peut être
inquiet pour disons que en 36 n'a
considéré frein certains ont considéré
que c'était une révolution on a fini par
comprendre assez vite que c était un
acquis social incontournable
et bah maintenant en fait au fur et à
mesure c'est grignoter ça va devenir de
plus en plus compliqué est de plus en
plus excluant le non départ puisque pour
un enfant par exemple le fait de rien
avoir à dire à la rentrée des classes
parce qu'il n'est pas parti sur les
attitudes m'attirant dès le départ leur
enfance compliquée pour commencer
l'année et même certains enseignants qui
évite maintenant que pose est celle qui
voit là en début d'année année après
année ça se confirme on en revient à ce
ciné débat comment ça va s'organiser
les réalisateurs seront présents voilà
un président national du secours
populaire sera là également
oui il y aura le président national et
puis on a prévu un petit témoignage
d'une référente vacances du département
pour un petit peu animé et puis les gens
qui sont là pour nous poser des
questions soit sur le film soit aux
personnes qui seront présentes hier des
témoignages mais qui sont apportés à
bord de cette soirée on quitte cette
actualité là ce sera demain je profite
de votre présence aussi parce que il ya
cet appel aux dons et la mobilisation
aussi avec l'ouragan l'ouragan matthew
là aussi un appel aux dons oui voilà bah
oui on est désolé invoque dans sa
demande de l'argent on aimerait en
demander moins ça voudrait dire qu'il
n'ya pas de catastrophe
alors pour haïti je me souviens être
venu sur le plateau lors de la dernière
catastrophe et malheureusement là
effectivement ça semble ça semble très
compliqué pour nos partenaires locaux
donc nous au niveau du département des
yvelines on intervient dans un cadre
régional ile de france du secours
populaire et c'est sur la région palmer
de lattes et on a un partenaire local
qui nous a alertés dès qu' il ya
commencé à voir les premiers éléments et
donc on fait un appel aux dons sur le
département sur l'ensemble de la région
et on va il ya encore un petit peu tôt
pour dire concrètement ce qu'on va faire
mais ce sera probablement un mix de
soutien alimentaire des de relogement et
qui peut-être vaccination puisqu'il ya
des risques d'épidémie qui sont assez
importants au niveau du choléra c'est
que si vous n'avez pas d'argent pour
vous pour donner pour aider le secours
populaire vous pouvez aussi donner votre
temps pour venir vous aider même pour
les paquets de fin d'année par higuain
d'autant que là on est un petit peu
ambitieux on a multiplié les jours donc
avant
étaient présents vendredi samedi
dimanche sur les paquets cadeaux
la fnac de vélizy 2 hélas comme les
besoins s'accroissent
on essaye d'être plus davantage présent
donc on rajoute le jeudi et le mercredi
est donc venez vous verrez c'est facile
même moi j'arrive à le faire et ça nous
permet surtout de financer les activités
de fin d'année où on est fortement
sollicité merci beaucoup pascal rodier
je rappelle que c'était et c'est est la
principale raison de votre venue ce soir
c'est demain mardi 11 octobre à 20
heures au ciné cette ce ciné débat
autour de ce film les vacances c'est pas
du luxe est un droit coût de l'entrée 3
euros et 50 mais vous l'avez rappelé on
peut donner plus
oui pour pas se priver voilà pour aider
secours populaire merci encore c'est
pascal heureuse tout autre sujet à
présent ils seront de retour en d1 en
première division ce sont les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux cette équipe de
baseball
après l'euphorie de la victoire il faut
maintenant penser aux objectifs de la
saison prochaine michael almy droit
rencontré la présidente du club
nous sommes avec la présidente des
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux annick
août on manie vous êtes qualifiés pour
cette première division après une finale
de playoffs on peut le dire plein de
suspense à tout à fait ça a été une
finale de folie vraiment et nous sommes
heureux qu'ils aient réussi à avoir
leurs objectifs à atteindre leurs
objectifs
c'était vraiment l'objectif de départ du
début de saison ah c'était l'objectif de
début de saison c'était l'objectif était
d'atteindre la finale
après une fois qu'on a atteint la finale
bien évidemment tout le monde veut la
gagner donc nous avons atteint
l'objectif et saint-just vous a posé
beaucoup de problèmes en vous lisiez
battu quatre fois sur quatre en saison
régulière là finalement ils ont pris
quand même deux matches
oui ils nous ont pris au dépourvu dirons
nous parce qu'il pensait bien que ça
serait beaucoup plus facile mais non il
a fallu aller en cinq matches et c'est
vrai que c'est quand même rare d'arriver
dans des finales en cinq matches en
général c'est 3 2 1
c'est plus là c'était difficile bon
c'était une belle finale ah c'était une
finale magnifique tout le monde s'est
régalé tout le monde a beaucoup souffert
avec les joueurs mais nous sommes très
contents du résultat et alexandre
couteau a été élu mvp de cette finale
oui il a été élu ump qui je pense que
c'est dû à ce qu'il a fait sur la finale
où il a quand même frappé un tour d'un
coup de circuit à home run et puis l'a
frappé le point qui a fait la victoire
dans le
match numéro trois et là relativement
bien frappé et puis il avait bien frappé
toute la saison donc il y avait été dit
qu'il fallait le surveiller pour voir ce
qu'il allait faire en finale
vous étiez peut-être trop confiants sur
cette finale avant de débuter cette
finale je pense oui son parti ayant
gagné les quatre matches cependant la
saison régulière ils se sont dit que ça
serait beaucoup plus facile mais
apparemment l'équipe de saint-just est
monté en puissance
il avait un petit avantage par rapport à
nous c'est que nous n'avions pas joué de
demi-finale puisque l'équipe que nous
devions rencontrer en demi finale a
déclaré forfait
donc le il avait quand même trois ou
quatre matches trois matches de plus que
nous donc nous nous sommes arrivés pour
la finale sans avoir joué depuis le 3
juillet ce qui a quand même été qu'il a
un handicap parce que les garçons ont
dit qu'il manquait un petit peu de
rythme lors du premier match à
saint-just
on va parler maintenant de l'avenir quel
sera l'avenir de des cougars de mon team
retenu l'intérêt c'est vraiment de
monter en première division du coup et
d'y rester à tout à fait cesser pour
monter à la première division c'est pas
pour faire l'ascenseur c'est pour
pouvoir y rester c'est pour pérenniser
notre place c'est pour continuer à
travailler pour pouvoir avoir des
joueurs performants et puis surtout
pouvoir entraîner des jeunes derrière
nous qui vont vouloir rester au club
pour pouvoir accéder à cette équipe
première qui est en d1 vous avez les
moyens de le faire nous rester en
première division
nous allons faire le nécessaire pour
pouvoir avoir les moyens nous allons
rechercher du financement
nous allons pouvoir rechercher des
joueurs aussi peut-être des joueurs qui
sont des joueurs qui sont en france et
qui vont pas nous coûter très très cher
et puis essayer de trouver peut-être
trois étrangers il est déjà une campagne
de recrutement qu'elle était lancée
je sais que les
les responsables de l'équipe une on
commence déjà à chercher et ont déjà des
pistes et pour l'instant aucun nom
pendant ce temps pour le moment pas de
nom non parce que nous n'avons pas de
certitude donc nous donneront les noms
lorsque nous serons sûrs et certains que
les gens voudront choix à montigny et
vous allez tout de même garder un noyau
dur de joueurs de mon team moto ne pas
tout à fait tout à fait puisque c'est
une équipe de montigné donc ta il y aura
d'abord des joueurs de montigny nous ne
voulons pas être un club de mercenaires
nous voulons avoir des joueurs formés à
montigny et avoir quelques peut-être
quelques apports d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
nous renforcer il vous comptez
éventuellement sur le soutien du public
également pour rester en première
division l'année prochaine vous faites
un appel peut-être ausy montant de venir
vous voir
tout à fait nous comptons sur le public
mais toute façon le public l'a bien
prouvé ce week-end parce que je pense
que c'est le public les a portés les a
aidés à gagner le public a été là
pendant tout le week-end tôt le matin
tard le soir donc je pense que nous
continuerons à voir du public les une
ville derrière mon team retenue oui on
est soutenu par déjà par la municipalité
à quiche que je remercie parce que je
pense que nous n'en serions pas là si
nous ne l'avions pas été aussi aidés par
la municipalité par la caisse qui mais
je pense que les gens et le centre étant
le centre sportif et en ont plein centre
ville
les gens s'arrêtent nous regardent et
s'intéresse au baseball oui merci
beaucoup a ni couteau et rendez-vous en
2017 pour voir évoluer les cougars en
première division
merci de nous avoir suivis c'est la fin
de cette édition demain mardi pour le 7
8 invités haussmann vendeurs d donnera
notamment la parole au nouveau président
du club d'aviron de versailles et puis
côté actualité il sera également en
compagnie de pascal thiery infirmière
coordinatrice aides et dons d'organes
sur le réseau ouest parisien et sur
versailles
ce sera à l'occasion de la sortie du
film avec mathilde seigner réparer les
vivants qui traitent justement de cette
problématique
excellente soirée
[Musique]